how'd this come about and why burritos
of all things why would that be exactly
yeah we were joking that we'd like it
here in the newsroom in DC as well well
it turns out the Virginia Tech is the
site of one of the six FAA approved
drone test sites so it was a perfect
place to gather data with some real
professionals and it also turns out that
Virginia Tech has a very aggressive
program for kind of next-generation
transportation and infrastructure so I
think it all it sort of worked out well
for everybody was the whose decision was
this son I mean it was alphabet is it
some kind of partnership is the burrito
maker involved and how will it progress
from here sure it's a partnership you
know the Federal Aviation Administration
alphabets really running the show here
there you know this these are planes and
it's a delivery system that they've
worked on for quite some time now
they've done thousands of delivery runs
out at their remote California test site
but they wanted to move to a somewhat
more urban environment where they could
test these drones in a more realistic
setting and the other thing they're
doing is kind of product is sort of the
testing the marketing they're gonna use
real people and just see if you know do
the burritos arrive still warm do people
like the experience and that sort of
thing as well yeah on that note I mean I
think of all the provisions of college
student needs I won't name all of them
here we could say notebooks and pens and
pencils and the like there was a reason
for picking burrito picking food it
provides certain difficulties that say a
notebook wouldn't that's right
so you so you know the notebook flips
upside-down when it comes out of the
package you're fine but obviously that's
not going to happen people aren't going
to be happy if their burrito lands on
their lap and you know speed is
important because you want to as I said
keep it warm and so they they actually
said in their purse release they wanted
to pick food because it was a challenge
Allen where
are we on regulation where is the FAA
there they release more regulations
recently but we're still not there
they're still as the comprehensive drone
regulation handbook is there well the
FAA took a huge step just a couple of
weeks ago by unveiling or their new
drone regulations they allow much
broader use of commercial drone flights
but when we're talking about deliveries
here that's a much trickier problem you
know the idea of especially over cities
with lots of people you know it's going
to require all sorts of safety systems
it's going to require a low level air
traffic system you know we're gonna
they're going to really be pushing the
edge of the envelope on sensors on
robotic technology and that sort of
thing the companies say they can do it
in single-digit years within a couple or
a few years but I guess we'll have to
see how long it really takes